Jeff works as a waiter
at a fancy restaurant.
He receives a base amount of $70
each day plus approximately $10
of tips for each
client he serves,
or $10 in tips for
each client he serves.
Assuming x represents
the number of clients
Jeff will serve in a day and
y represents his daily salary,
draw the graph which
represents Jeff's daily salary
as a function of the number
of clients he serves.
So he's going to get
$70 no matter what.
So even when x-- so even if he
serves absolutely no clients,
he's going to get $70.
So when x is equal to 0, his
pay for that day is still $70.
Then he gets $10--
they already told us
he gets $10 in tips for
each client he serves.
So if he goes from serving
0 clients to 1 client,
he's going to get $10 in tips.
If he goes from serving
1 client to 2 clients,
he's going to get
another $10 in tips.
If he goes from serving
2 clients to 3 clients,
he's going to get
another $10 in tips.
And you see that
this line represents
all the different
possibilities for him.
If he goes and serves
6 clients, he's
going to get $60 in
tips plus the $70.
So the $70 he would have made
otherwise plus $60 in tips
gets him to $130.
So this right here is the line.
So we could check our answer.
We got it right.